[Music]
being a chef for me
is the only thing i could imagine me
doing in my life
people ask me what do you do when you're
not cooking
cooking
my name is pam i'm a chef in bangkok
and i have a restaurant in my home
called the table
i cater one table a night they can
request whatever they want no
restrictions
at first it started off with the people
that i know my friends my friends are
friends
the waiting list now is three months
[Music]
john george is a famous chef
and he owns a three-star michelin
restaurant in new york which i used to
work at
i decided to come back to bangkok and
open my own restaurant
and i didn't open a restaurant
instead i invite people to my own house
[Music]
today my guests request called crab
pasta
and beef wellington
i will go shopping for ingredients
[Music]
i try to focus on local produce
bangkok is a very special place for a
chef because there's thousands and
thousands of ingredients here and the
flavor of each ingredient is really
distinctive
and then i will come back home and
prepare it a day ahead
i usually finish about 80 of the food so
when the guests come nothing is chaotic
in the kitchen anymore everything is set
[Music]
i got two helpers in the kitchen
and service people for front of the
house
everything is clean and ready to serve
[Music]
i'm glad that people see that i'm
successful but i don't think that i'm
successful to the top yet
if you think you're successful you'll
stop learning
being a chef or being a cook you always
have to learn new things
[Music]
i just love what i do i think it comes
out in the food
if people come here and they go back
with smile and
full stomach
i'm just happy
being a chef is not a job for me it's my
passion
[Music]
[Laughter]
you